par l'état monsieur pierre lequiller oui
monsieur le premier ministre françois
hollande manque singulièrement de vision
et d'initiatives concrètes en matière
européenne notamment sur les deux sujets
qui vont être traités au conseil
européen de demain c'est apple a plus
d'europe ne suffisent pas il faut des
actes
en premier lieu face au problème capital
des migrants qui risque de durer des
années
il faut refonder schengen cela passe
rapidement par une politique d'asile
commune
il faut pas tout en europe le même
statut de réfugié et la même politique
de reconduite des migrants économiques
en situation irrégulière dans leur pays
il faut rapidement une politique
solidaire de contrôle des frontières
extérieures de l'europe avec des gardes
frontières européens en renforçant le
rôle et les moyens de frontex
deuxièmement la zone euro sur ce sujet
françois hollande a fait des effets
d'annoncé sans jamais les défendre
devant le conseil européen jean-claude
juncker à lui-même fustigé le mutisme
français sur le sujet de la zone euro
lors de ces sommets nous l'est
républicain appelant à une refondation
de la zone euro avec un président stable
un véritable fonds monétaire européen à
partir du mécanisme européen de
stabilité
troisième sujet le référendum
britannique dont il faudra bien parler
un jour puisqu'il est fondamental pour
nous il faut évidemment aidé david
cameron a gagné le référendum pour le
maintien de la grande-bretagne en europe
les crises européennes et nous en
traversons plusieurs d'une gravité
exceptionnelle ne peuvent plus recevoir
des réponses tardives et au cas par cas
elle nécessite des réformes ambitieuses
alors demain sur ces sujets quelles
propositions concrètes
françois hollande va t-il enfin mettre
sur la table
merci monsieur le député la parole et
aux secrétaires d'état chargé des
affaires européennes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
député lequiller mesdames et messieurs
les députés ces sujets ce sont ceux qui
seront à l'ordre du conseil européen qui
se réunit demain à bruxelles et qui
permettront à la france de demander que
soient d'abord mis en oeuvre les
décisions qui ont été pris en matière de
réponse à la crise des réfugiés à la
fois lors d'un conseil extraordinaire
des chefs d'état et de gouvernement qui
se tenait au mois de septembre et lors
des conseils des ministres de
l'intérieur auquel bernard cazeneuve a
présenté une feuille de route en commun
avec l'allemagne pour que nous puissions
avoir une réponse qui soit à la fois
conforme à nos principes
c'est à dire ceux du droit d'asile mais
qui met aussi en avant la crédibilité de
la réponse européenne en matière de
contrôle des frontières extérieures
communes de l'europe car comme l'a dit
le ministre de l'intérieur la
soutenabilité du système d'asile
européen qui passe par la mise en place
des centres d'enregistrement les fameux
hot spot suppose qu'il y ait
effectivement un contrôle et une
distinction entre ce qui relève de la
protection internationale et ce qui
relève de la lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière
à cet égard la france a aussi renforcé
sa contribution à l'opération en
méditerranée eunavfor mais qui est
désormais baptisé sofia et qui a l'appui
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
pour lutter contre les trafics contre
les réseaux de passeurs en mer
méditerranée qui ont provoqué plus de
3000 morts depuis le début de cette
année cette crise des réfugiés
elle passe par la solidarité la
répartition sur laquelle nous nous
sommes engagés collectivement de 160
mille réfugiés qui seront accueillis
dans ces hotspots mais aussi par une
coopération très ferme avec les pays
d'origine et de transit pour les aider à
lutter contre les passeurs mais aussi
pour faire en sorte qu'ils accèdent dans
le cadre d'accords de réadmission que
soit retourné vers les pays d'origine
ceux qui sont en situation irrégulière
nous négocierons également à
l'initiative de la france et de
l'allemagne et du président juncker un
plan d'action sur ce plan avec la
turquie
voilà l'action de la france elle est
concrète et elle sera efficace
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
un monsieur philippe courbe